like how you think affects how you feel
and then how you feel affects how you
behave so if I think angry thoughts I'm
gonna feel angry and then I'm gonna
behave angry
[Music]
so this article is kind of more like a
just like a little life lesson in
perspective
um I don't know if you guys ever watched
American Idol back in the day like
season one like the old Seasons yeah
Kelly Clarkson dude do you remember
Kelly Pickler I remember Reuben Studdard
oh okay I remember Clay Aiken I remember
Fantasia or something now we're just now
we're just making people up no dude you
know Fantasia dude yeah
um yeah there was a girl in Kelly
Pickler season five she was uh she I
think was she was a country style singer
she didn't win or anything but she's one
of those ones that made it big after uh
so highly successful country singer she
ends up marrying another country music
writer named Kyle Jacobs and um Kyle
Jacob Jacob's a successful musician also
like a songwriter
um he does an Instagram post about how
an album he was working on went just
went platinum like big celebration
um also he's unveiling this app for
music musicians that kind of connects
the community like all good news the
next day he shoots himself oh geez and
uh yeah they have no there's no um
reason to suspect Foul Play they know
that it's is there a suicide no is that
why I don't know they don't know yet
there's a straight up note but they
they're not calling it anything other
than yeah damn all right but the crazy
thing is just that you think about these
situations where you somebody seems to
have everything like going for them yeah
like and they're hitting home runs like
one after the other Grand Slam in it and
then what could you know what could it
really be you know that's bothering them
and um and yeah this is just another
example of that where like even if
you're under the spotlight and people
are like wow look at you you got it all
it's like does he really does anybody
you know obviously this reminds us of
like twitch and [__] right you know what
I mean like um dancer who recently also
committed uh suicide and it's like
sometimes and again this is just
debriefing amongst like close friends
that like had to like get through the
trauma of different a Community member
you know like basically you taking his
life but there's always this weird
feeling where you know people that you
put on pedestals people that you glorify
are like you consider like heroes or
Idols from your community right they
maybe maybe feel the pressure that they
can't dump like their problems on you
because you're the one who's asking for
help all the time but you're the one
that are constantly like wow you you got
it like you made it you know what I mean
you're such an inspiration that no
matter how [__] kept together
everything looks especially on the the
fake ass life of social media where
people only promote what they like
choose to or like maybe it makes more
sense for their business you know what I
mean to do things a certain way it's
like that that must be such a lonely and
difficult thing for the people that we
actually put on pedestals not just the
people that like don't have all the
Glorious opportunity you know so I can
only imagine like especially if
everything sounds squeaky clean perfect
how much difficult [__] that person
might actually be going through
individually you know yeah I think like
it's really people become like true
misery is when you because when you're
poor right and you actually like you
look forward to like making money like
when I was poor I was like oh if I just
have five thousand dollars a month I'll
be set I don't know if you guys ever
felt that but yeah but when you actually
hit it you're like you need more so this
desire keeps coming right and I think
true I never understood why rich people
killed themselves but then it got to a
point where I was making money like 30
40 G's a month and I was like the most
emptiest at any like compared to when I
was young and that's when I realized
that's true misery like you're thinking
that you're gonna make this money and
it's gonna make you happy but you reach
that level and it doesn't yeah and
that's when you're just you can't live
because you feel like you're you know
you're you're depressed and you're just
existing and you can't die because
you're afraid of death so it's like you
can't live you can't die you're just
existing and I I feel like you're empty
with no purpose yeah because you thought
you got what you wanted exactly they
call it like the hedonistic treadmill or
something is that what it's called we're
just chasing the feeling yeah because
it's like whatever level of Joy or
satisfaction that you hit
um that new one is your Baseline right
you know like if you ate at like [__]
JJ's or whatever like oh [__] that's
really good but then you eat I like
sugar fish now that's the new Baseline
so every so if you don't hit this then
the next time you go back to JJ's that's
subpar yes whether it's your career or
how much you make or whatever and then
so in our brains we keep trying to chase
the next one but it's how hard is it to
[__] keep out doing yourself yes
right so you have to like somehow
um figure out a way where the
satisfaction and reward doesn't come
from external but from internal and
that's the tough part to figure yeah
that's hard right does it mention if
they have children or anything like that
um I don't think they I'm not sure if
their kids didn't say but um yeah one
thing that it does show too is that you
don't have to justify that you feel like
this based on your life like I think if
you're on the low and you feel like you
know ending it all like it's just as
valid as somebody that's on a high and
also feels the same way I got a fitting
quote what's up for this [__] moment
all right better not be the [__] tree
falls in the floor is who hears it
I don't know yeah that's okay
now if you farted at JJ Cafe no I'm just
kidding
Epicurious all right he's a [__]
philosopher and he says do not spoil
what you have by Desiring what you have
not remember that what you now have was
once among the things you hope for yeah
wow you are living the dream that you
wanted yeah but you can't even enjoy
that dream because you're thinking about
the next time about something else yeah
and I
so [__] guilty of that yeah for sure
like I'm you know now I'm in you know
Hawaii I've been wanting to live there
I've been wanting to do this and now I'm
just like what's the next thing because
my mind is just wired to to to look at a
goal and my eyes are at that goal and
I'm not looking at now yeah yeah really
easy to fall into that trap yeah because
I enjoy the game like of trying to
accomplish something but then I'm so
focused on the future that you're just
not like wait a minute this is what I
wanted right now and I should enjoy this
a little bit constantly unsatisfied with
where you're at yeah for no [__]
reason if you make you make reasons to
be unsatisfied well you punish yourself
right you always look at all the reasons
why you're not where you want to be or
why yeah and you think about what the
stuff you have it's not good enough all
your friends are dunking on you for
having a brown belt like just it's tough
out there you know dude I'll leave right
now bro I'll get the hell out of here
oh God I'm not a rebel black belt is
there like a specific think like if you
were
um like speaking to somebody when you're
when you're ministering and they have
those types of feelings is there
something you usually go to whether it's
in the Bible or for something you've
learned yeah I always I utilize the
Bible but I also utilize a lot of
analogies you know so what I talk about
is the levels like say for example a
person from a scale of zero to a hundred
if a person
um thinks that they're like level let's
say the real level is level 50 right and
but they they think of themselves as
level 80. even if they get things that
are level 70 in the in life they're not
going to be happy do you understand what
I'm saying yeah so I tell them how do
you humble down well you got to think of
yourself as nothing actually because
when that comes let's say you are like
level 80 but you think of yourself as
like a level 20 right then even when you
get level 30 things you'll be happy
you're grateful yeah so that's where
like I kind of teach people and they're
like oh everything starts from the heart
bro honestly like I can have everything
in the world but if I just feel like
empty then that's what's going to lead
my life you know when I went to Africa
right so I went to Africa for like
missionary trip and there was these kids
that have to so there was Civil War in
Africa right 15 years they didn't have
running water they didn't have
electricity
these kids were like playing with a
soccer ball it wasn't even a soccer ball
it was like a beach towel rolled up but
it was like 50 kids playing with it yeah
super happy yeah they have no running
wire they hike like two miles each way
to get water and bring it back right
no electricity they use candles at night
you know no restroom anything they dig a
hole in the ground but when I saw them
like they're so much happier than me and
it didn't make any sense to me like I
we're in America we turn on the faucet
we use it you know what I mean like
magic but there's always complaints in
my heart like man I wish I was in a
better family like it was actually the
the heart that was like messed up and
that's what I learned like okay this is
this needs to be fixed before anything
else and that's what BART was saying
like internally that has to be fixed you
know so how do we fix it well it's a
spiritual thing for me you know
personally where when I think about it
like okay you know what do I have like
when a thought comes to me for example
I'm lonely those thoughts come all the
time you're lonely but think about it am
I really lonely could I not call the
homies can I not go out can I not like
oh it's this little thought that's
leading me to be crazy and why and I'll
just kind of talk about this real quick
like I have a friend who he he's like
kind of like a porn right like he he's a
mattress model right is what they call
it right here
he's living the dream right so he has
sex with like a lot of women and this
dude he he goes in raw like straight up
he never wraps it up right so a few
months ago he hit me up and he was like
hey Johnny I have AIDS right like HIV
AIDS whatever and almost like what the
hell I wasn't really shocked to be
honest with you I'm like bro we should
in our industry and the way you do it
right yeah but in my heart I was like
you know I kept having this question
like but how does he know that right
like so I asked him did you get tested
he said no bro like I lost weight I have
symptoms I'm like what the hell and then
he but then he says a girl that he was
messing with was like tested positive
right so I'm like okay regardless of
what that is like that's the situation
you go and get tested right and then
he's like no bro this guy's atheist he
doesn't believe in God I'm like bro I
feel like your thoughts are attacked
he's like what the [__] does that even
mean my thoughts are attacking me so he
just like blew it off right this dude
sends me like a text message a couple
months like two three months later he's
basically saying that he's gonna kill
himself you know and I'm just like what
so he texts like these this long rant I
could see the roller coaster like I hate
God if God was real why would he do this
it's like all this and then it goes to
like remorse and then it goes like you
know it's like going everywhere yeah and
so Ireland right right so I I'm at
Lancaster State Prison and I'm like all
right I'm just gonna drop everything I
end the class like quick shoot down back
to you there's an Alhambra shoot down to
Alhambra he lives in a back house his
parents live in the front house he lives
in like the back house like I'm knocking
on the door whatever whatever he's not
opening up right so I I bust like my old
criminal ways man I mean like hop in and
I'm like you know I'm a bigger dude so
I'm getting in this window and I see
this dude like he has this Blank Stare
like this distance there yeah he's in
his boxers and he has his nine
millimeter and it's on his hip so he's
about to do it straight up and so when I
get there like I'm like bro stop doing
that like relax and he's just like he
just looks over like I'm gonna do it you
know I told him look give me like three
days to a week let's go get you tested
let's figure he's like bro I like he
blew up on me right then he's like I
have it like I don't know what you're
talking about like uh so anyway I have
Kaiser okay I take him with me we pay
for a full panel draw his blood swab
everything right we basically pay for
everything we test for everything so we
get there
um after three days 72 hours and you get
the email and it's he's basically
negative for everything yeah he's
negative for everything he doesn't have
A's to have anything but what was
causing him like like let's say he
smoked himself that day it would have
literally been for nothing yeah but what
was causing him was it really that he
had AIDS his paranoia odd exactly yeah
it was the thought that was leading him
exactly so it comes down to that bro you
know like always our thoughts come and
oh you know you're you're lonely you
don't have anything actually this guy
the the husband he has everything
actually but he wasn't able to stop and
actually process it he just like how you
think affects how you feel and then how
you feel affects how you behave so if I
think angry thoughts I'm gonna feel
angry and then I'm gonna behave angry
right so I'm gonna do be violent or
whatever so I I really think like
it's really important for people out
there listening to really think like
about think about your thoughts as crazy
as I said sounds funny to say think
about your thoughts people get defensive
when you tell them you can control those
words in your mind and you can control
those thoughts they get so mad yeah
because they're like no you don't know
you don't ever been through what I did
it's like you can choose how you tell
your own story definitely definitely
it's a skill in itself right learning
how to check yourself
celebrate by having more sex
so he comes to church with me now
straight up straight up yeah yeah he
comes to church that's amazing yeah
I mean that's doing God's work bro like
I feel like you know I left the church a
long time ago but what you're actually
doing is true Christianity true saving
you know other people like they're so
smart I hate no we didn't have we didn't
have people like that when they sit
there and judge you and say you're wrong
you're going to hell don't do this don't
do that that is the kind of love lacking
Christianity that I [__] hated that's
what's that's what could turn you off to
the entire thing absolutely yeah they're
just getting angry judging you but then
like true love is when you're just like
man you made mistakes so did I but like
I know you're still welcome yeah
absolutely right absolutely
[Music]